news out of the Supreme Court the court
just ruled that the Biden
administration's student loan
forgiveness plan is unconstitutional the
White House estimates the plan would
have affected 37 million Americans and
was set to forgive up to twenty thousand
dollars in Federal loans per qualifying
borrower the plan has been on hold since
Six republican-led States who claimed
the program violated President Biden's
executive power took the administration
to court but the Biden Administration
argued the plan is permitted within the
law inside of the heroes act which
allows the Secretary of Education to
make changes related to student loans
during National emergencies like the
covet pandemic